hello and welcome to spectator out loud
the podcast where a few of our writers
from each week's issue
reads out their pieces this week we're
going to be joined by paulina noeding
a swedish writer who reports on the
country's latest crime surge
we'll also be joined by toby young who
talks about how he was wrong to back
boris
and finally lloyd evans on his theater
review from the magazine this week
and why to go into the theater during
the time of coronavirus is just so
different
first up pauline annoying we have an
obvious problem
admitted the swedish prime minister
stefan levine recently
he was referring not to the covet
pandemic but to a summer of crime
that has left even jaded swedes reeling
in disbelief
their regular bombings hand grenade
attacks and shootings
young men are killing each other at a
horrific rate
10 times that of germany the feeling is
growing that the government has
completely lost control
yet while le'veon has finally
acknowledged the existence of the
problem
he still seems in denial about its true
nature
last month in buchurchia south of
stockholm a twelve-year-old girl
walking her dog was killed by a stray
bullet from a gang shooting
and in a tv interview her friends
explained that shootings
are simply part of daily life in their
neighborhood
one child said that she hears gunfire
from her bedroom window
almost every night and this is perhaps
what's most shocking for older swedes
how resigned the children in these areas
are how much they've grown
used to the violence it is all too much
for mats loving
the deputy national police chief who
earlier this month decided to speak
plainly about the nature of the
criminals he and his colleagues are
fighting
there are at least 40 family-based
criminal networks or
clans in sweden he confirmed immigrants
who came to the country solely for the
purpose of
organizing and systematizing crime
according to loving they make their
money through drug trafficking and
extortion
and have a great capacity for violence
the interview was a bombshell the prime
minister has always tried to talk about
crime as a socio-economic problem
and he stuck to this line in response to
loving saying that
i do not want to link crime to ethnicity
a government mentor which insinuates
that even asking questions about the
link between crime and immigration
is xenophobic but the issue of course
is not skin color it's about the problem
of an
important type of crime families from
non-swedish cultures who stay in their
own circles
and prey on swedes of all ethnicities
these are people who have set up
parallel systems of government that
challenge the swedish state
something that politicians cannot bring
themselves to acknowledge
conflicts between rival criminals last
month escalated to a point where gangs
took an unparalleled move
to establish their dominance masked and
armed men set up roadblocks
and controlled cars entering certain
neighborhoods in gothenburg
streets were deserted as the gangs
ordered residents
to stay inside the headmaster of a local
school
put it bluntly checkpoints controlled by
criminal militia are something
i last saw in afghanistan i never
thought
it would become a reality in sweden
meanwhile home visits from doctors have
been suspended in the area for safety
reasons
and staff from care services for the
elderly and disabled
are being escorted on their rounds by
security guards
the government's solution to problems
like these has long been to deny their
existence
when people began to talk about no-go
zones a few years ago
the phrase caused so much anxiety in
official circles
that the crime spots were dubbed go go
zones
in a pr initiative for years the
government's position
as well as the narrative reiterated by
large parts of the media
has been that the notion of rising crime
is some kind of fake news
based on this idea the state has set up
a pr budget
and employed staff to write
fact-checking posts to deny
international reporting about what's
going on
one of the so-called myths busted is
that shootings have increased
only weeks ago prime minister stefan
levine famously claimed that even if
there were a crime problem
it was nothing to do with immigration
any love leader of sweden's center party
says that
many of these gangs and their families
have been in sweden for decades
as if this would contradict the notion
that immigration and failed integration
is a root cause of the problem
prime minister levine has even pointed
to upper-class youths in a small suburb
of stockholm
as an explanation for gang murders
maintaining that
rich kids consumption of recreational
drugs
is creating a demand that leads to
shootings in poorer areas
can you really think that drug abuse
among a small fraction of the country's
youth
explains why there are 10 times more
gang murders in sweden
than in neighboring countries but
although it is willing to scapegoat
affluent teenagers
the government has so far remained
silent about the changing nature of the
crime
some of it's so grotesque that it's hard
to discuss
at the end of august two teenage boys
were abducted
raped and abused for 10 hours at a
cemetery outside stockholm
when police found them they had been
stabbed and buried alive
somehow they survived these deplorable
acts of aggression now have a name in
sweden
so-called humiliation robberies are on
the rise and the victims are often
children
and young people who are not just mugged
mainly by immigrant youth
but also subjected to all kinds of
horrifying and degrading treatment
because of the threat to children
swedish parents are beginning to wake up
they're beginning to realize that their
children are not growing up in the low
crime country they themselves knew
and they feel that the time to talk
honestly about it
has long since arrived
that was paulina and now toby young
i admitted i was wrong to back boris
a friend emailed me earlier this week in
despair about the prime minister
quote boris reminds me of a hereditary
king
edward ii or henry vi who is so
staggeringly incompetent
that he must be removed before doing too
much damage
i felt the same way about may but boris
is worse
unquote he's not the only person feeling
like this
it pains me to say it but i too have
given up on boris
the final straw was hearing him talk
about his plans to create
an army of coveted marshals last week
britain's very own
curtain twitching version of the stasi
what on earth happened to the
freedom-loving twinkly-eyed
rebel asian character i voted for oliver
hardy has left the stage
replaced by oliver cromwell his
government
has even said it wants to lower the
speed limit on motorways to 60 miles per
hour
didn't boris once say that voting tory
will cause your wife to have bigger
breasts
and increase your chances of owning a
bmw m3
where did that guy go
some people think it's all to do with
his bout of coronavirus
as one person put it to me surviving a
near-death experience can affect people
in one of two ways either you become
more
devil may care thinking it could all end
at any moment so why not live life to
the full
or you become super cautious having been
left
feeling vulnerable by your brush with
mortality
according to that armchair psychologist
boris has gone through
door number two a less generous theory
is that the disease actually damaged his
brain in some way
and there is some evidence that
cognitive decline can lower your
appetite for risk
whether the damage was psychological or
physiological
the implication is clear he's no longer
fit to be prime minister
and should step down as soon as he's got
brexit done
this explanation is attractive to former
boris enthusiasts like me
because it lets us off the hook it's not
that we've overestimated him
rather that he's changed in a way we
couldn't have anticipated
but the difficulty with those theories
is that his mishandling of the crisis
predates his battle with covid19
few would dispute that he failed to give
the pandemic the attention he should
have done
in january and february time he could
have spent devising
an effective containment strategy come
march he was just buffeted by events
one minute saying we should take it on
the chin the next imposing a full
lockdown
his lack of engagement with the detail
both before and after his spell and
intensive care
means the government's response has been
led by others around the cabinet table
like matt hancock who seems to be wholly
captured by a small coterie
of scientific advisors who decided early
on
that sars cov2 was the big one
and have been unwilling to abandon that
hypothesis in the light of all the
evidence to the contrary
boris supporters cannot claim they were
unaware of this risk
his inability to focus on anything for
very long was constantly flagged up by
those who'd worked closely with him
most recently at the foreign office my
response when this was put to me by his
detractors
was that he had been preparing for the
role of prime minister all his life
had a heroic conception of himself as a
world historical individual
and wanted to be installed in the
pantheon of immortals
as one of britain's greats so even if it
was only for vainglorious reasons
he would apply himself in number 10 in a
way he never had before
hal would become henry v not henry vi
unfortunately boris's critics have been
proved correct
funnily enough one of the most prominent
michael gove
is now de facto deputy prime minister
four years ago when justifying his
decision to knife boris in the tory
leadership contest
go said it was because having seen him
operate up close
he'd concluded he lacked the character
for the top job
not lazy exactly but not serious enough
at the time i took this with a pinch of
salt thinking gov was
exaggerating to make it sound as if he
was motivated by
public spiritedness rather than personal
ambition
now i think he was right hope followed
by disappointment
is a familiar story in politics a cycle
as old as history
itself i should have been better
prepared
in future i will not be so naive
that was toby young and now lloyd evans
arriving for a weekday matinee at the
bridge theatre i was greeted by stewards
holding illuminated boards please wear a
face covering
inside the seating had been rearranged
into clumps of twos and threes
with the odd single perch sticking out
like a toadstool
nicholas heitner the artistic director
offered us a pair of the best loved
scripts
by his favorite living playwright alan
bennett
the afternoon was stuffy and i took sips
from a bottle of water
in accordance with signage which
suggested that masks might be removed
for the purposes of drinking after each
glug
i diligently replaced my covering 10
minutes into the show
i was visited by a covid marshall who
informed me
that the position of my mouth wear
dissatisfied him
can you put your mask over your nose i
keep seeing you taking it off
i did so he crept back to the shadows to
continue
spying on me how bizarre a stalker
hired by the theater was policing my
every move
this level of dictatorial intrusiveness
will kill the theatre
an audience can't possibly attend to a
drama while the isles are being
patrolled by stalinist busybodies
licensed to select victims at random and
force them to make
minute adjustments to their apparel the
theatre is about showing us
our better selves if it turns into a
grudge match between art lovers
and philistines it will die the
performances were excellent
but the atmosphere was muted and uneasy
in the first play the shrine monika
dolan played a widow
whose motorcycling husband has collided
with an oak tree
she visits the crash site to kneel and
pray wearing a hi-vis
jacket to prevent another mishap but a
bothersome
safety inspector terminates her
devotions you're an accident waiting to
happen
he says clearly nicholas heitner hoped
this script would amuse us with its
topical themes but our present woes make
it ten times more depressing than alan
bennett can ever have intended
in the second play leslie manville
delivered a heartbreakingly funny
performance of
bed among the lentils even bennett
skeptics will find it hard not to admire
this exquisitely crafted portrait of the
vicar's wife
who rails against her captivity in a
dead-end parish
sadly the audience in the half-empty
house responded with far less merriment
than the performances deserved actors
who can't hear peals of laughter
will look out for the next best thing
smiling and grinning
the sight of parted lips and white teeth
heartens a comedy performer no end
but this too has gone another victory
for masks
over art the bossiness of the bridge
theater was equal by the regime at the
royal docks
learning and activity center the venue
required us to soak our hands with jin
scented muck on arrival
and to occupy socially distanced benches
masks were compulsory
even though the playing area was
outdoors the show
called 843 was a medley of speeches and
sketches
inspired by the blm movement as we
waited for curtain up
a recorded voice howled extra rules in
our ears
stay seated during the performance do
not move from your benches
first a platelet featuring an american
policewoman who sought permission
to murder an innocent pedestrian i'm
armed and ready to engage sir
the threat level is pretty severe he's
sitting there sir breathing steering
did this come from a genuine police
transcript or was it a piece of fiction
that uncertainty weakened its impact
next
a dialogue about a black yorkshire man
who wanted his white father-in-law to
understand oppression
when the father-in-law offered his point
of view the black guy retorted
suck my mum instead of feeling
apologetic he was thrilled
and elated by his sudden outburst
this interesting piece was too short
merited development
third a revolutionary speech from a blm
agitator
i was there blood or bone fist or bottle
the uprising is coming ready or not
that's fine but smashing things up is
unlikely to lead us to a happier society
finally a monologue about an overlooked
scandal
black and ethnic minority people died
disproportionately as a result of force
by the british police
said the speaker the phrase as a result
of force
was carefully chosen to cover a vast
range of cases
a mentally ill man restrained and killed
in a police station
is very different from a career gangster
shot dead by jumpy armed cops
on the streets but both were included in
the catalogue of slaughter
in order to substantiate the view that
britain's police forces
are assassination squads lefty activists
love to promote this falsehood the
speaker revealed that 1
740 ethnic minority citizens have died
at the hands of the authorities in the
last 50 years
she added that criminal proceedings have
yet to be brought against any of those
responsible
this bank catalogue needs to be examined
afresh
but the investigation will be
strengthened by the removal of cases
in which the police acted justly that
was lloyd evans
thanks for listening to this episode of
spectator out loud
and do join us again next week
you